hello hello hello everybody what is up
what's going on it's Wednesday everyone
happy Wednesday and we are here GameSpot
live today we're sponsored by you piss
off thank you very much because we are
gonna be playing some Ghost Recon
wildlands yeah
I'm precious this has been you know you
know what it is uh but yes so what
what's going on is there's there's some
some crazy Ghost Recon like there's a
teaser announcement tomorrow yes
livestream yeah yeah and there's a whole
bunch of they put in a mission they've
had some trailers come out that are kind
of teasing what it might be
take a look at those yeah exactly
so starting with the first teaser
because today we're gonna be playing
operation Oracle which was just released
May second but they also released it
with this awesome teaser so let's go
ahead and check yet you know switch over
here really quick
seems that we've got to work out a sound
thing really quick so pardon us yeah for
a second
some real real fun yeah background stuff
going on here haven't having some fun
trying to play the the trailer there's
some real cool music that plays during
this one and I want to make sure that we
hear it it's it's definitely a thing
so we're you're doing some some hardcore
work on this but it'll be there shortly
in the meantime though this mission
we've played through it a couple of
times now and it's got some really
interesting things we'll get to the
layout basically we're gonna watch this
trailer we're gonna see what what
they're kind of building towards with
the tease and then we'll actually play
through the whole mission and see what's
going on there yeah and then we're going
to then move on to the second teaser
where they talk more about what happens
in the mission to kind of maybe get
better insight on what's gonna happen
with the actual announcement tomorrow
which I'm excited to see what it could
be but a lot of people have noticed too
from the thumbnail this has got the
Punishers actor in how're you doing I
mean you know obviously we've seen him
in a lot of stuff
Punisher Walking Dead I think he's
perfect for this type of role too like
in Ghost Recon it was checking out as
I'm DB and he has a specific character
that he plays and he fits right into
that again inside of this actual mission
so it works out really well that way but
you can't see stuff but soon we're gonna
be good because I think we're almost
ready so we got got some cool cool tech
stuff going on and I think we might be
set to roll here thank you we're rolling
hey I'll switch or the trailer really
quick you know hundred times but it's
when you go live is when technology
doesn't want to work but it's fine we've
got this now let's check out this
trailer yeah let's let's hit it
y'all are ghosts top-tier operators to
quiet professionals bravest of the brave
tip of the spear all that and a bag of
chips but even a bad [ __ ] needs
help once in a while good thing for you
I'm a ghost too
[Music]
so that was the the first tease that we
got to see of them being in the game
which was really cool and there we go
and now from from there we're going to
move on to the mission is there anything
that you you kind of picked up on that
that trailer that you want to so first
things first obviously I think it's
super cool we got Jon Bernthal playing
this role because he's obviously like
really perfect for it we've seen him in
a lot of roles or it's just like
action-packed I mean obviously Punisher
Walking Dead and stuff but what also is
interesting to me is he's like good
thing for you I'm a ghost too and like
the only thing I could think that a
whole time is just like is it good I
don't know he looks really intimidating
and threatening but it Leon actually
point second point it's nice to see some
some personality and the ghosts like
that you know yeah yeah are are you are
you ready to jump in I think we all
right so now we're gonna actually play
through the mission that we just saw the
teaser for yeah um so yeah right now I
got a retrieve Bowman's package so only
me I could just take the bike which
would be faster but you know I want my
homies yeah you come with so you gotta
roll roll on by with everyone so the
there's a some cool kind of like driving
we get to do some introspective time to
kind of think and talk about it exactly
lots of driving in this game which which
helped me get better at actually driving
the cars in this game because you know
sometimes see I appreciate how how just
loose the kind of driving is yeah you
can go off of jumps you can roll your
car and stuff and that's the kind of
thing that I really like it's night time
we're extra sneaky that's gonna say
we've picked the perfect time to sneak
in here and do this mission yeah so I
know this missions been out for a bit
has anyone in the chat played it well
what do you guys think of it
oh and you can't talk about Ghost Recon
wildlands without talking about some of
those I know some people in the chatter
mentioning Rainbow six and Splinter Cell
with the crossovers they did they did
especially for me because I really liked
splinter salty did Sam Fisher some some
really good justice in the crossover
they had with them even referencing the
fact that we don't have like Metal Gear
games anymore and I thought that was
really cool and I definitely didn't
almost cry at my desk work when I first
saw the cutscene yeah hey anything that
can invoke that type of emotion out of
you pretty yeah I'm playing like oh this
is a really cool military tactical like
we got to sneak in and take the dudes
out I didn't expect to get like a weird
emotional thing like that at the end of
it but I definitely appreciated it
alright so we are a little far away from
the start of this mission that's okay
yeah it's it's all good
see yeah there's a good point key points
out when the game is on sale now it's
not too much if you want to jump in and
as far as I know this oh oh oh
control drips it was it was going so
well I don't know what happened I got
scared it's all good it's it's dark out
the roads are dangerous
interesting oh so in walk in I don't
want to run them over
alright we're rich whoa explosions you
know you're in a good mood for a good
time when they're just random explosions
yeah completely random explosions that
explosion has nothing to do with us a no
yeah she oh I should probably not talk
cuz I think we're about to get some
exposition here
oh I know exactly what's happening right
now or we cannot hear Karen as you could
oh wait I was gonna read it off but it
was super curious unidad currently is
holding him at an underground research
facility and that card should open the
security door check your map for this
facility's location all right so we've
got a location of a fazil of facility I
know exactly how we can fix this
actually so once this is done I'm gonna
switch over to the camera if we're gonna
fix this - one step at a time where all
of this was working before we yeah all
right so yeah because I got 1.9 ask for
the controller here really quick and
there we go should be good now then
fixed it you guys bring it back to the
game been fixed
I'm snowy got all the the dialogue back
audience said which is interesting point
yeah
so I believe shade in the twitch chat
mentioned the scale tech teaser which
we're gonna be watching after they
finish the mission yeah being more of a
direct teaser for whatever they're going
to be announcing tomorrow I think that
lines up
yeah I think all their tears are so far
different but very well thought out so
I'm very excited to see the reveal
stream tomorrow all right
so we're on the train tracks we're close
an odd route to take but definitely a
good route to take to a secret bunker is
this a thing with yet is the thing with
Jon Bernthal the Punishers here but he's
a ghost now
yeah he's a good thanks for mentioning
hey yeah it's it's a good call out shade
I'm glad so I like that when we do
streams like this we can have people who
are like justice is kind of excited for
it as we are yeah I just like live
streams in general all right so we've
reached the bunker I had the access card
I'm ready to go in and see what's going
on Raisa pew-pew so Kiki also says do
you guys recommend the standard game
I personally myself I kind of recommend
going for the one that's a little bit
more because it has the Splinter Cell
stuff in it but that's just cuz I love
Splinter Cell so I was running around
with wasn't the five-seven from
conviction and the SC 5000 I think is
what it's called in this game all based
off of the the weapons of using the
different undersell game it's massive
keep your head on a swivel just keep
your head off your head on a swivel
y'all it is really weird that we went to
the secret basin there are no guards
here there's a lot of ammunition crates
though which is always a sign of
impending battle yeah yeah all right so
we got to find this engineer right see
some bodies hitting the floor here
that's will really keep your head on a
swivel please still don't don't stop
swivel they've been constant swivel so
it sounds like a professional stir
coming through here knocking out
scientists and taking out bad guys it
almost seems like someone did all the
work first someone might be punishing
some people okay
I hope the multiplayer stays the same
for a multiplayer from future soldier
I'm curious to see if there will be some
sort of multiplayer something because I
know that it was kind of a big deal for
for wildlands I kind of missed future
soldier a bit I like that that went a
lot
yeah everyone is laid out you say we're
just following the bodies on a stroll to
try and find our man missing all the
things to tag I mean we could grab all
that stuff all right some actions
there's also some of the things that
we've already picked you up because
we've actually played through the
mission already but looks like we're
getting some exposition yes cut see but
turn up the volume a little bit
there is no mad Walker hell are you
doing here Bowman didn't say to expect
you tough little handler of ours got no
idea I'm here what hundred huntin trip
what's the game level practising Daniel
is this deal CEO of anyone this is the
the free DLC update ago company
technology that the government does not
want shared but he's been spending a lot
of time and Bolivia mm probably not out
here soaking up the culture huh he's
been selling secrets to unidad so he and
I we're about to have a little chat our
mission from Bowman was to rescue him
from uni dad I could blow sunshine up
your ass all day but I'll spare you
Bowman fair enough he's my real target
they know exactly what he's been knowing
she's been protecting a little [ __ ] what
a twist
what's he do for them inform me inside
you today these must be some pretty
serious secrets for you to go off-script
must be like born to hunt each Donna's
like chest bag oh yeah after he was
talking about going on a hunting trip
that's just aesthetic he's all about the
hunt we follow me and do as I say
YouTube doesn't make it out
not yet it's all your business right
mind your business
Jonny excuse me there you go yeah yeah
let me put some respec all right so now
we we got some people time to earn our
pay
Oh already I like to use the drone just
to mark people it's a solid strategy
like that's so I at least know what I'm
getting myself into I do this you get
that recon like that guy's oh just shot
it
yeah shoot my drone like that see a lot
a lot of people big fan a big fan of the
punisher stoked to see him kind of
hanging out in here okay he's a pretty
big-name actor which makes me wonder
like what cuz this is all this is all t
towards whatever is happening now I
wonder what his part is like in all of
it if he has like a bigger part I was
like wait a second that thing looks
flammable explosive barrels oh oh he ate
that like a champ
alright we are engaged hostiles engaged
he's out here don't shoot
let's check around that corner
now okay okay it's gonna be a second day
right now of course where were you and I
am really good at hiding oh yeah that
was my superior aim clearly nailed it
the reloading takes too long it's its
tactical you know you got it you got to
pace it out oh and the word I was just a
warning she's like can I didn't do that
nope probably with a stronger sniper
rifle maybe because there's a lot of
material penetration in this oh there's
a third Wow
all right I'll ring it I will fall back
your look the photo should do something
I know come on Johnny come on Walker do
that thing my eyes are pretty smart oh
oh shoot okay it's that guy in the
corner dead all right yeah he's good he
gone
switch shoulders which I like ow
oh you can't be behind those corners
can't believe it they taught these AI as
well oh that's right he'll get you back
up what hit me
he'll get you it's all good yeah well
you got all your other pals here -
they're just hanging back
come on homies I like can't move the
camera either and so they start helping
me here for you - and they love it
okay okay who's out here back in it yeah
this music is uh it's got some tension
to it
those little flares of guitar definitely
making me excited all right just like
waiting for someone to pop out of a
coroner's away oh my gosh again I'm I'm
dunzo come on Weaver you're right but
the drop shot I need my husband come
back earthquake I don't know what my
guys are doing L need this oh wait I can
actually set them to Lake but they'll do
it do you think there you go there we go
now we're on just watch commands lookin
I'm charging in yeah there we go there
we go
oh there's a guy right there it's real
unfortunate that he was trying to hide
behind that yeah I'm excited for
tomorrow - I want to see what they've
got going on a match made in heaven I
already showed I'm weigh-in no wonder he
was worried about the me now he's
jealous yeah
I kind of think I prefer the
third-person 80s same I think just for
this like more for precision stuff maybe
first person but I like that they give
you the option oh oh oh oh no oh no oh
it's fine everything's fine
see it let me see let me send my little
drone my drums got my back okay
usually my team's got my back oh no you
know what you're getting a promotion
holt because that was fantastic
heck yeah okay so now we gonna get our
cardio in Jody breeze says so what's
this about a wildlands if so let me get
ready to pee or it we don't know what it
is yet but they're announcing it
tomorrow it's a special livestream so
we're just we're kind of checking out
all the stuff that they did to kind of
like tease whatever their heel - is just
in there I love that he's just using
that Desert Eagle and nothing else he's
walking into a room slowly and just
popping people and ryebeck okay see some
people kind of bars got a sniper wrong
shot him in the toe oops
you're in the way can I match this oh he
dodged it
oh no okay he's got some arm around in
the toe again it's fine you've got
flipping not Frank Castle here
everything's fine that's a natural
inaccurate reaction to what's happening
right now what is this what day is it
I I don't know Bob where we're going
crazy today oh there is I was like
someone is right there Yatim and I know
it's gonna be some homies down here
[Music]
imagine being that guy that just felt a
bullet whizzed past your face and the
person behind you dying you're like well
guess I'll die then didn't even react
he's just like I can't get here because
you have the silencer on but he felt it
yeah you're the body drop oh yeah
alright where is my hostage get a move
on Daniel he's there dang Danny back at
it again run through the tunnel go pick
him up
time y'all gotta leave a space for
Daniel come on Daniel you're almost
there
I believe in you you can do this oh cool
like a guy oh my gunner weekend we got
enough seats on everyone house super
excel here Ruta pullout let's do it
don't hit that okay why don't you guys
German shots we are streaming on Twitch
right now straight now easy peasy cute
him do this safe house I know she's so
touchy about it it's like how can you
not suspect yeah right some sort of
nonsense just get him to the safe house
stop ask your questions it's also kind
of strange how the whole conversation
just gets dropped by everyone who's
trying to like figure out what's going
on but it's fine because I mean we're
not we're like halfway through this
almost there's still stuff to happen
there's still stuff it's gonna
yeah and we've come up with not mine
I'm sorry super I'm I'm actually looking
at two different chats I'm trying to see
as much as I can but I I do see you and
I'm sorry that I missed your first
comment alright we've delivered amigo
take care and stay out of trouble
you got a boss take it easy see you
later
whatever you say Karen now let me take
this van this minibus cuz I like these
sick decals on the side that uh oh man
my bumpers falling off I go see someone
about that mess it's all good I yeah I
understand I just want to make sure
everyone feels like that their stuff is
seen you know cause I care about you
guys don't care about it you guys I'm
driving just far enough to get out of
this circle not yet no not yet
gotta do some super sneaky surveillance
yeah
so our homies over there and we need to
tail selective you where
he's moving he's moving in the grooving
oh man
stair was too tall there's snow on him
they're slippery I see lots of red over
there so sneaky sneaky beavers it's
headed up over this way yeah
where could they be headed what could
they be doing can't see me I'm laying
down has the world from your starting
yet no that's all tomorrow we're kind of
just looking at everything that's kind
of come out to try and kind of like
super might be doing cuz you know
tomorrow's gonna be a big reveal and
they've taken a lot of time and effort
to release its missions and these
Caesars so even pull them upon her Frank
castles to hear but it's not Frank
Castle it's it's a completely other
person but yeah
how much of the DLC for this game is
story relating how much just for fun
seems like a lot of it is kind of like
like we were talking about earlier the
they had the rainbow six mission they
had the the splinter cell mission that I
really enjoy I feel like this is the
main one that kind of serves a story
purpose or helps T's like this price
really important guys seen lost I don't
want to read taking another call but
madrone he's got a cool down yeah me boy
Karen wants to speak to your manager
classic Karen alright we've snooped
around some fishy nonsense is going on I
agree
can't let it go me too vehicles is Nomad
cult relation between Bowman and the
engineer they're meeting up in person at
a farmhouse alone without security I'm
not burning bridges yet I want to see
what this meeting is all about before
you go I want to show you something all
right and now we begin our drive there
is a helicopter on the other side of
town I don't know if you want to risk
that I do like helicopters it's fun and
it is pretty far well let's go assess
the situation it looks like it might be
just far enough out of the red zone just
take it and not have to worry about
yeah yeah I mean worse that happens
really turn on and see it shoot at you
and while you're flying away just gotta
be quick perfect no one sees a thing no
they don't they just suspect me no one
sees anything oh also one moment
[Music]
and we're back
perfect all right so now we got to go
talk to Walker who's very far which is
why we stole this helicopter 13
kilometers away that's a bit of a trip
but it's fine so we got the chopper I
really love the way this game legs
though I actually made this drive like
the last time I played and you go
through all the different terrain it's
nice it's like it's all snowy and then
it's like desert II yeah I think it's
like check out all the different
landscapes it's kind of cool to just
kind of have the the moments in between
to travel and kind of maybe catch up on
a side mission or something too while
you're on your way there oh yeah I love
how my homey is just magically appeared
in my chopper dude hey they're ready to
go they all right that's that's how you
define ride-or-die right there whenever
I need them boom it's over either all
right so we are well on our way to go
see Walker at his special airfield but
obviously from what we've gathered so
far in the mission is that he's on to
something he's a very suspicious of
Karen he's not happy with how things are
going currently he doesn't want to
respect the authority right now but us
being logical people we're like we need
answers yes
that's where we're trying to try to
figure this out there's a lot going on
what's what's good who's bad what's the
deal
Jerry wants to know how everyone is
today how are you doing how's your
Wednesday yo I'm doing great
sidenote oh look there's something
written on the floor
aha environmental storytelling we found
I actually forgot just how fun this was
last time we like drove halfway and then
we stole a helicopter now they have a
radio and all the vehicles but no radio
and the chopper Oh done just because the
the helicopter sound is like a much more
it's just kind of a comforting sound
just the blades cutting the air you know
it's it really is the the perfect
vehicle to use for reflection for a long
ride yeah thinking about what the
Punisher could be doing any given moment
helicopters are like insane to me
because if you think about it's like
ceiling fan about like a high-powered
ceiling then yeah I'm into it
i I no matter how many times have seen
games too I never am comfortable with
the people sitting on the outside like
that like that seems not safe I'm not a
professional great especially if I'm
like moving like this their balance is
fantastic yeah right there's no seat
belts as far as we know there are no
seat belts right we're finally almost to
Walker leave it up to Walker to make us
come all the way out here for this lease
out landscapes all nice and green eggs
we're out of those snowy mountains
amended that private airstrip I don't
know you I don't like winter I don't
like the cold I could do without Bob
Jones must know does the not Punisher
have a skull shirt we can only hope
okay be a great pilot that precision
yeah don't don't high-five anyone
outside of a helicopter that's a good a
good rule if you have the like arms ban
no like qilin or maybe I definitely
don't but I think average arms might be
safe I'm too afraid to do anything near
a helicopter it's just too much oh
here's our man here he is just standing
there menacingly damn Daniel why he
leads tech that gets our men killed good
this whole situation blows before we
start handing out payback let's see what
the hell
revengeance mission let's view this
document I think is the trailer yeah
cool cool so that is the trailer and now
we gotta go find Daniel because this all
crazy fool put a tracker on him and he's
1.4 kilometers he probably used that
helicopter again oh there's a second
helicopter here too unless you wanted to
drive it out yeah we're gonna roll in
well there we go cuz we get the radio
again yeah some tunes but now we're
getting a little more context right his
men they were did they were killed
because Daniel gave out some tech so of
course naturally if he finds all Karen
he's working with them
he's not gonna be happy about that
engineer go without being able to find
him again
now put a track on his ass I put a
tracker on his ass the kid mission and
the delivery of that line was no oh I
can feel it he was proud of it you're
doing someone some sweet off-road angels
do the predator mission our mission is
while very cool not tied to the
announcement tomorrow as far as I know
alrighty so now we're close to the base
no dad's here do like like how many good
sneaking opportunities there are around
here oh it is the middle of the day - so
that's gonna make it kind of interesting
situation Greg says just got here during
live players or just you in the squad so
we're doing solo right now just for the
sake of having the extra backup we were
originally going to have both Persian
and I playing but I got too scared
spotted a group of tangos
it's like 15 here gotta be a platoon
thank goodness for this bush yeah right
well ultimate camel I know you sneak up
on him give him give him a good old
melee to hug plus I want to drag him up
and hide him so no one knows I killed
them
what are they announcing tomorrow not
exactly sure but it's something Ghost
Recon related and apparently these
trailers that they've been putting out
and this mission that they put in the
game are kind of like a teaser all
teasers kind of pointing towards what it
could be but yeah so we're just kind of
playing through it and taking a look at
it
oh that scared me yeah that scarecrow is
doing his job it is job is this new
story content it's not new new but it's
it's fairly nice that's really I came
out in the second yes all right so
should we just destroy everyone and then
get the guy or should we be sneaky we
could try a little bit of sneaking I
always like trying to sneak and then
ultimately ending up not doing it well
everything all right let's see if we can
sneak up on this guy
ooh no hello no hello we're hi okay
let's do that
oh there's another guy God got it all
right well there goes our cover there's
only like three people it's fine okay
don't shoot civilians that's a no-no but
um this guy that guy definitely not a
civilian definitely can go I didn't want
to risk the head shot because whoa whoa
Bob Jones coming going guns blazing no
one wants to see that stealth oh I know
it's kind of how I recon admittedly the
new ones where is she where are the
drugs I don't like how boys pacing back
there don't
that's not stepping in also you didn't
check his line of fire that way I know I
was standing right here Walker I thought
this guy was supposed to be a
professional what is this awesome next
I'll be here tomorrow sweet yeah we got
we got some plans for what we're gonna
do for for the reveal tomorrow you can
we mention them now Robert so they
aren't
um well Jack Pattillo will be in the
studio with us there you go we're gonna
watch the reveal stream and then chat
about it obviously because it's a big
deal oh my gosh I pressed the wrong
button but yeah so that's what we're
gonna be doing tomorrow has a little bit
of a post stream because we land check
out what's going on
and then obviously want to geek about it
and I guess uh Walker is not coming with
us he's just he's trying to figure it
out
think real hard there yo okay so now we
gotta go find Karen she got kidnapped
she don't care snaps Joe I am NOT
driving to a very good place let's go
this way
all right so here we go
okay such a big gun to have on a car I
wanted to avoid that base that's in
between here and the mission so I had to
drive around it sounds like a very good
option avoiding any unnecessary fighting
is always a good thing
all these are rocks here ooh oh my
Rodan yeah completely off the road homie
I'm the gunner AC is actually in the
most dangerous yeah because we go
rolling let's get back then we can hear
what she has to say for herself
I love how rational we are in hey it's
alright everything will be fine let's
just do this first
[Music]
why the message is taken away people
just choosing to to redact them maybe
there's like a misspelling or like okay
through the mountains I see lots of
purple over there yeah I'm not fairly
certain we're about to try to break into
a place you don't want to break into
okay there it is
so growly we've got to start snooping
without any of these hombres catching
sight of us guys we were like alright
guns blazing and then the immediate next
mission don't be detected yeah it's fine
I don't think it'll be too bad if if you
get spotted either way but I'm here for
the the same old like try to stealth and
then great cuz that's like the theme
yeah we're ghosts I'm all about improv
both in life and in video games
oh my gosh I like I weighed down income
it's great that Camel wind acts up oh do
not have to worry about that while we
run these usually the people in the
towers are the ones I like to take out
and then I'll just be sneaky yeah cuz
their whole job is just to look out for
people just take out the people who
looking out for the people then it's
much easier to move around sight jamming
us
oh that that pinpoint yes right on top
of them oh okay guns blazing
it's okay they'll forget all about me in
about five seconds ain't no thing oh
yeah so if you aren't even pretending
he's not the Punisher hey no it's it's
something they don't like you out of
there I get out of it oh yeah they're
mortars I forgot about this yeah as you
say that thing might blow I was like the
second I thought on fire I was like
uh-oh this is bad
oh no no this is really bad yup house
yup I'm here to help get you back up oh
boy oh boy oh boy okay okay no that was
almost really cheap I almost couldn't
get out of there we got these guys who
are running in okay more mortars yeah
yeah oh there are car oh all right you
know ah ah you're just I'm gonna be a
ghost again I want to be a ghost horses
wanted to be a ghost
Christian comes in and says we soft have
been on a roll the story content lately
I agree I kind of like this like almost
hitting it from all angles kind of
aspect of teasing what they've got
coming up like giving people who are
current players something to play inside
the game they already have to help build
up whatever it could be on top of
putting out kind of cool teasers they've
got the celebrity help too yep it's a
it's everything mystics homing in on me
I'm like what are they oh my gos she's
not supposed to see me so we're looking
for someone in here who can tell us
where she is
so it's always that weird part of like
finding out where exactly they are find
someone who looks like they're important
enough to know where and they barely
like the brand that just like have a
different armor on or something or they
won't have armor on and they're just
like regular person trying to like hide
in buildings before the little marker
comes down where that was very close
yeah those are really far away
Wow the eagle eye it's really far it
doesn't matter if you know they
shouldn't know we're still hunted yeah
he didn't notice it's all good now oh
you see a museum
alright thought I saw me oh wait okay
I'm just seeing things I guess where is
this guy I thought it wasn't in these
buildings from the middle well I see
maybe is that one next to you there's so
many people though Oh found it here's an
oh my gosh they're all here oh all right
now we know exactly where to kind of
look for him he was in a different spot
this time that's that's kind of the cool
thing about it though that like it's not
really the same every time you do it the
first time I did it I was like I didn't
kill anybody almost only accepts in that
beginning brain I was like man what's
going on here yeah darn it got me hey
you know uh standing next to a gas tank
that was on fire what it's an honest
mistake anyone would have made it it's
so big you wouldn't even think it was a
thing to like pay attention to I'm just
like take cover like oh man
oh it's still muck though oh man so we
know exactly where to go
well we're gonna take this trip again
and hopefully the unit a the officer is
in that same area is or is it just
marking the areas and not marking them
so my it might just be the area
I think that she's speaking towards a
different mission because right now
we're trying to find her stop it
stop confusing our viewers Dan Karen
yeah see that was a part of a different
mission but it's fine all right let's
see if we can see this a little more
stuff here than before I'm starting to
think that maybe he that is him still
marked maybe the area is definitely
murdered so I think once I get you got
Eric to do that thing for every one of
the meeting I said hi somewhere
underground let's go find a basement
find the basement
yeah so the guy looks like a normal
person we get that oh yeah I can't use
the drone yeah him and everything I've
leaned on that drone too much I know I
definitely do because now that I can't
use it I'm like oh man this is dangerous
yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh boy okay he might be in that group
over to the left you can start trying to
identify the people as you see him yeah
this is probably not him someone's
getting into a truck
all right so
so check that out there close that nasty
looking dump okay it was in this area
you try to try to just like look at the
the guy who just got on that truck
because it might be him there you go
perfect we're gonna run up on it there's
guys over there though there's like
there's a lot of guys that grab them
guys over there take it take it behind
the wall there we go perfect okay good
oh I stopped breathing for a second
we're getting that that real
first-person interrogation
I'm Matt thanks information and quiet
thank you for marking it on my back now
let's get out of here
teammates detective Lee for what are you
doing here you had one job dude you're a
ghost it's fine
ghost access is revoked you're out of
here Weaver oh no it's fine it's fine
it's fine
we're just hunted now
oh crap it's for this is fine this is
fine yeah
we can't go oh pot twist can't believe
it yeah I'll save you guys by getting
out of this area
kind of goes have work in 20 minutes
goes the best have fun for the the
announcement yeah thanks for hanging out
Jason it was good having you have a good
day at work and look forward to seeing
you in the chat when we were here for
that that reveal see what they've been
cooking up oh I can't shoot through that
Oh what the bullets are too big yeah I
like that like like that the sound when
the bullet hits a lot
yeah like that little confirmation good
alright so how come oh come on yeah some
sweet rock climb in action yep alright
this is up withdrawn everything's good
you're in the clear only I could that
might be too big just go around on the
left or you just do that - sure come on
yeah all right all right now we're good
wow we're really in agreement okay so
Bowman's over there and I like to take
this little mountain route because you
get a nice little view yeah give me
something - sure we could have we could
command our squad to stay put but I also
kind of like having them around in case
I mess up cuz then they can carry me
okay my characters a little tired I was
like this is me in real life the second
I have to run anywhere like out of
breath fuel up okay let's go so no I do
the I do the oh no thing a lot it's a go
- what up Ian how's it going when we
played those together it was like the
fastest imaginary scooter we're just -
and to do it alright so we've made it
also we didn't try sneaking once when we
played it I'm gonna just preempt this
and not embarrass myself and just go
straight for it alright make our way
down the hill here we do have people
six-shot life is a good life sync shots
one of my favourite things
oops oops
when climb doesn't work all right
so hello we're the same thing to work
every day nah I got like literally just
five different shirts which I should
probably get more well actually have
more because I have the the other Jean
ones that I got I'm feeling particularly
a Canadian alright we'll make it happen
y'all okay so I got my sing shots in
it's got Christian asking what time the
strum is tomorrow I'm looking at our
notes here just to be absolutely sure it
is tomorrow at 11:30 a.m. Pacific so
early in the morning for Pacific people
and sort of like midday for people on
the other other side of the country
I'm not going to other time zones and
I'm sorry for that but I can't tell you
what it is in other parts of the world
off the top of my head okay hunger
someone behind like to the left or
something this purple yeah I see the
purple but what's going on let's go Oh
Jody says they've also got your ready
for work nice watching team making good
videos and hope everyone enjoys the
stream thanks for singing thanks for
hanging activity sorry I'm falling apart
but uh it was good having you and I hope
you have a good day at work oh maybe
that purple is them downstairs I think
so
all right lots of stairs more cardio
yeah it's it's important to get your
stairs in whoa some parkour I think we
might be up on the stairs
actually maybe ok I have this sniffle
thermal vision where I can get psyched
out by a light okay let's go see it's
over here
I hear you yelling you sound very
frazzled by something can be me Oh found
him yeah Adam yeah that's the only other
that
there might be someone else well because
they're still purple there yeah whoa
that's a first someone drove their
vehicle in here alright thanks for
hanging out Tomy it's good good senior
take it easy you're definitely more
aggressive in there
what difficulty probably normal yeah
whatever the default culty was for this
I don't have anything to prove I'm not
the one playing foot I do appreciate
that this game does have a lot of really
good options if you want to make the
game more difficult like you can turn
off the HUD turn the difficulty up to
like realistic oh my gosh he threw a
grenade at me paint for me
heck I'd probably play on the the easy
like arcade mode of difficulty if I
could to be honest
you bust out the noob tube I'm about it
so you say new tube I say pro pipe pro
vive I like it
that was my defense whenever I kill a
region
oh my gosh someone's behind me oh my
2000 chill here for a bit yeah pull out
that their regular assault rifle
thanks got him thanks Weaver another
cars coming yeah this is the third
driving into walls
whatever you think might be good just to
move to the next part of it I don't know
if they're gonna stop or maybe that
other guy is calling them in you guys
were just in time things we're about to
get stressful for me
stressful a icy rescue oh shoot it's
like so dark yeah I'm also excited for
the reveal tomorrow zombie okay we had
two guys and so I'm just gonna get out
of here just grab one of those cars
drive away uh-huh I just take I just
take the car and drive down the tunnel
it probably works out pretty well
already take the stairs up - it's like
if you want to chase this hope your
cardio zone play put you in shape not
gonna lie I seriously thought those as
an older Ghost Recon for like ten years
ago or something that night-vision
filter right the great thing about night
vision is it kind of makes all the
ghosts Rico it's it's like the signature
look for Ghost Recon because I there are
a lot of missions that you had to just
night-vision with all right turn off the
lights to be extra yeah yeah yeah
so tomorrow frequent they're going to be
announcing something new for Ghost Recon
not entirely sure what it is yet but
they've put out these teasers that were
going through today on the stream we
watched the the initial teaser that
showed the actor from The Punisher being
one of the main characters in this
mission that they've added - Ghost Recon
wildlands so we're playing the mission
now and then there's also a teaser that
they put out
this that we're going to check out once
we finish this mission which is almost
just gonna drop Karen on Pearl who
I guess you figure you've got it all
worked out like you got the big picture
let's save the chitchat for the
safehouse
I love how the safehouse was extremely
close to where she got kidnapped could
you imagine if you're making like a Tom
Clancy Punisher game that'd be that
would be wild that would be an extreme
crossover all right so this is the the
end of the mission the last cutscene
i'ma turn up the volume a little bit
with the games what's this all about
is it about it's about you helping to
steal information from the government
giving it to unidad I didn't steal
anything I was helping a spy an enemy
spy now hold on my orders were to
protect him for the success of multiple
US interests in Bolivia and the Bolivian
people spoken like a true traitor
whatever happened to loyalty to country
you should have killed that engineer the
second you knew he turned if you could
protect a man like that what's to keep
you from selling information yourself
[ __ ] you I had orders and I was
following them drag him you orders got
my man killed hated enemy I'll take
yours shove up your ass Walker now this
[ __ ] gets dirty we all get paid to root
around in the scum now we come out of
that muck as clean as we can
lissa know what side I'm on hmm
look I'm sorry for the loss of your men
really now I might strut around like I'm
the [ __ ] of the walk but I don't call
the shots
I follow orders [ __ ] you had command
on the ground you call the shots every
time you obey an order listen you've
been out there this is an impossible
situation at least Bowman gives a [ __ ]
you trust this boot you gotta trust
somebody Walker
she was waiting in the back she's like I
want to kiss you you for now I'll just
her you keep your nose clean moment you
owe me for the lives of two of my men
you straight what I order this Saturday
I'll come and I will collect on that day
mmm we've got trust that's good it's
like a secondhand trust though yeah yes
that's so boom that's the mission teaser
so we should get the the next teaser
queued up or yeah we got anything we
won't want to talk about before we head
into it whoa oh well you know what let's
do the teaser first and then we can talk
about it in a lump sum because like
it'll be easier to streamline it that
way so I'm gonna switch over to this
right and we're gonna bring this down
and we'll have the the teaser here in
just a second yeah yeah
and moment of truth you guys cool so we
looks like we might not have the the
audio again here one second
trailer trailer tech is something else
you guys will get it here in just a
second this is the the big one though so
we should see if this works
alright it looks like I might have to do
the long solution so that's me I want to
sit here I'm gonna get to talk to you
guys for just a little bit but yeah so
that mission was pretty cool I still
like that they've got that that actor in
there it's kind of weird that he only
plays like one type of character though
it seems I didn't know that he was in
The Walking Dead until just this morning
because I'm just not in touch with
everything but that's cool I don't know
what else he was in I have his IMDB page
pulled up because I was gonna start like
listing off facts but I got too caught
up and actually like what was happening
but yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah the the actor for the Punisher and
I should just look at what else he's
been in so I'm just not up on top of it
there's a lot spoiler it's just a lot of
things Oh like one of his credits is
from like other games so he has history
of working in games that's really cool -
you like fun fact yeah yeah
says here that that's a good sign you
know well on our way he's in Fury tank
movie I think I've heard of fury I never
watched it though hi my name is on the
trailer it's here yeah alright so we're
gonna we're gonna switch it back over to
the PC here and we're going to let that
play out here in a second so uh hold on
and we'll have a trailer for you hi my
name is Jace Cal I'm the founder of hi
hi my name is Jay skel hi my name is Jay
skell I'm the founder of scale
technology ever since its creation scale
Tech has been harnessing innovations in
industrial science to serve the common
good
we had scale tech dare to dream big and
strive fearlessly to achieve those
dreams every day we work tirelessly to
enhance technology and our quest to
create a better world today the entire
team at scale Tech is proud to present a
new range of drones for public and
personal use agriculture transportation
security maintenance our families of
autonomous machines are designed to free
mankind from its tedious limitations
making day-to-day life more peaceful and
accommodating to a meaningful existence
throughout the world a skel farmer for
example is a revolutionary drone capable
of seating and toiling difficult soils
providing food for the most remote
locations on the planet the scale
pollinator can be used for flower
pollination as a substitute to bees
ensuring our biosphere develops and
thrives for decades to come
the scale doctor is specialized in
emergency intervention delivering
medical support in the most trying
scenarios these are but a sample of the
new series of drones we're launching new
models upgrades and specialization kits
will be released in the months and years
to come such as a scale handy
and the city chairman a drone capable
patrolling our streets to keep them safe
and secure I hope you're as excited as
we are we are working without boundaries
to bring to life the world of tomorrow
scale technology a better future today
[Music]
exciting yes so that was kind of like a
like a bit of a look at like a here's
here's our outlook for the future these
cool things that we're creating to make
everything the betterment of everything
brought to you by us it's like they mean
well it is what it seems like but it's
also a little eerie right because it's a
cover I don't believe it not for a
second we've been like trained to like
fear like robot takeover and stuff like
that so I think like just pay something
that alone I'm like oh the other thing
is - they're brought up during the
mission that they this company also
makes a lot of the technology that the
ghosts use which means they're involved
in military-grade things which is always
a scary bit when you've got a forward
facing public company that is making
things that are supposed to be for the
betterment of everything but they're
also dabbling in military technology so
right it's like very much walking the
line of something huge on the way that
you know could be good and bad right
because some of those things but like
robot that Paulo needs like in place of
bees like that's something I can imagine
actually maybe existing one day and
probably helping the earth and stuff
like that cuz you know everyone's always
scared of losing the bees but the other
thing about the technology is that it
kind of all feels like it's within reach
for like even IRL you know yeah that's
more eerie too like it's real like it
could be real when they like within our
lifetime that's the thing about a lot of
the Tom Clancy stuff I think is that
it's all kind of set in like a weird
believable future time with things that
are kind of grounded in reality and it
kind of preys off of the things that we
are kind of a little bit afraid of
possibly going wrong and that's
definitely playing into a lot of what
that
you're wonder what we were just watching
what we're talking about it's the the
most recent teaser for the announcement
that they're going to be making for
Ghost Recon tomorrow yes tomorrow at 11
a.m. Pacific yep and I think we can show
also their like announcement tweet that
they made which also shows the link that
they're reveal stream is gonna be
happening on is on their Twitter so
tomorrow May 9th at 11 a.m. Pacific time
so Ghost Recon calm slash reveal also on
Twitch and on YouTube youtube.com slash
Ubisoft and we're also sponsored by
Ubisoft today so it's been really fun
kind of putting all of these pieces
together right
we have operation Oracle where we're
introduced to Walker and he has you know
valid reasons to be upset if you know
what he thinks of caring is true so
that's also a weird play because he
seems pretty convinced already that
Karen is is no bueno yeah and it took a
lot of convincing a whole two missions
of convincing him to kind of be like
alright I'll trust you a little bit I
guess
alright and you know he's also burned he
lost his men he wants answers
he's like also kind of crazy like he
does off Daniel laughter he said he
wanted to see his family no remorse so
he's definitely like being pushed to the
limit right now yeah the universe and
see what happens I'm I'm excited for
tomorrow yes I am excited too I'm like
really eager to see where this goes with
the scale tech teaser and also the scale
technician that we listen to his calls
on in the operation he's talking about
you know we're gonna make it to this
island his wife is like an island owned
by your boss like is that such a good
idea what is going on an island owned by
the people who are making all this stuff
sounds like yeah let that sink in for a
second like they need a whole island of
their own to develop this technology
it's not just the medical you know BOTS
and the bee's knees that they're working
on must be something crazy and I'm more
interested to see where Walker Lee
might fit into all of that sound yeah
it's it's definitely odd I have
something big planned I think cuz you
know you're just pulling like a big
accurate huge character and your teasers
and not exactly Emily you know this
mission was fun but it's also kind of
short so as a fan like I'm desperate to
see more of Jon Bernthal like working
with Ghost Recon so I'm super interested
in seeing how the streams gonna play out
tomorrow what you know we're gonna be
surprised with and I hope you guys tune
in too because after the reveal right
after the reveal we're gonna be doing a
little post show here at GameSpot HQ and
Jack Pattillo is gonna be in the
building to witness the greatness I'm
excited yeah he's uh
I'm excited he's gonna have his beard
he's gonna do it there's still time
before tomorrow you can do it yeah it'll
be good so I hope that you guys show up
tomorrow and watch this core reveal with
us yes please do it's gonna be a great
time and you know I mean I'm always
excited to hear about new games so tune
in I hope you guys have fun playing
through the mission with us I'm sorry I
died once I'm not proud of that but it's
all good it happens and yeah we will see
you guys tomorrow and thank you for
tuning into GameSpot live today is
sponsored by ubisoft yeah good times
the guess the that about does it you got
anything else you want to say before
before we head out are we good um no I
think that's it we do tomorrow we'll see
you guys later bye everybody I'm gonna
find the button here I'm gonna do it
you